in this video we're going to talk about
the quantity theory of money which is
based on what is known as the equation
of exchange and it tries to relate the
money supply m
so this is some measure of the money
supply
with
the
real gdp
y so that is real
gdp
and the price level p
so this is price
level and we'll try to make this
tangible in a second and then it also
introduces this idea of the velocity of
money which is a measure of how much
that money supply is how quickly is it
circulating if there's a dollar out
there how many times per year is it
actually changing hands velocity of
money
and the equation of exchange that is
used in the quantity theory of money
relates these as following
that the money supply
times the velocity of money
is equal to
your price level
times your real gdp and we could view
this on a per year basis
so let's make this a little bit tangible
and actually let's try to make it
tangible by making velocity tangible
let's say we are in a world where
we have whatever we're using for m
whatever measure of our money supply
let's say it says that we have 10
billion it's a relatively small economy
right over that is our money supply and
let's say that our real gdp in this
economy this year
is going to be
100 billion
100 billion i'll just call it per
year
and let's say the price level and this
is usually some type of index this is
1.1
so one way to think about it if you take
your price level times your real gdp
so if you take this product right over
here that's going to give you your
nominal gdp
nominal
gdp where if this was 1.0 that would be
in reference to some year that you
consider your base year so this would be
your real gdp in terms of that base year
and then you would multiply it times
this right over here to get your nominal
gdp
but given this information pause this
video and try to figure out what the
velocity of money would be for that year
well this is relatively straightforward
algebra to solve for v we just divide
both sides by m
and we would get that our velocity of
money in this year is equal to our price
level
times our real gdp
divided by
our
amount of money
and so this is going to be equal to
we have
1.1
times
100 billion
billion dollars per year
divided by 10 billion dollars divided by
10 billion dollars so what is this going
to be 1.1 times 100 is 110 divided by 10
is 11. so we are going to get this is
going to be equal to
11. the dollar units would actually
cancel out and all you're left with if
you try to look at the units is 11 times
per
year and so one way of interpreting this
is for these numbers your average dollar
is going to circulate 11 times per year
if this idea still seems too abstract to
you think of it this way let's have an
extreme economy where we only have two
parties and let's assume
that our price level is just a simple
one in which case our real gdp would be
the same as our nominal gdp and let's
say that our gdp this year is 100
billion dollars 100 billion dollars per
year
and let's take an extreme situation
where
the amount of money that we have is
also 100 billion
well this would be a world if there's
only two people in this economy where
maybe this person just pays that person
billion dollars in order to get that
much worth of output
and so every dollar has just switched
hand once so the velocity of money in
this situation it would be just one time
per year but imagine another scenario
where instead of m being equal to 100
billion dollars imagine a situation
where m is equal to
one dollar
where there's only one dollar there you
could still have a gdp of a hundred
billion dollars because that one dollar
could just switch hands a hundred
billion times it would happen it would
have to happen quite rapidly for it to
all happen in the year but this person
could buy a dollar's worth of goods and
services from this person and that
person buys a dollar's worth of goods
from that person and it would go back
and forth 100 billion times and so in
this situation where you still have the
same real and actually nominal gdp if
your amount of money is 1 100 billion
then your velocity would have to be 100
billion times higher
now the folks who like to think about
this equation of exchange and the
quantity theory of money they're often
known as monetarists
and monetarists believe that inflation
is fundamentally a monetary phenomena
that if you increase the money supply
that that's going to lead to increased
inflation and if you decrease the money
supply that might slow inflation or even
result in deflation
so if you want to think about inflation
in terms of money we could solve for p
from this equation so to solve for p we
would just divide both sides by our real
gdp
and so you would get
your price level is equal to the amount
of money
times your velocity
times your velocity divided by
divided by
real gdp and these monetarists will
assume that velocity is constant
although folks theorize that maybe it's
not constant that technology for example
might make it a little bit easier to
transact which might make velocity
increase there could also be a world
where just people's mindsets make them
want to transact more or less which
could change velocity but monetarists
tend to assume that this is constant
because it frankly allows you to make
conclusions from this equation of
exchange
and monetarists also assume that changes
in the money supply will not have an
impact on real output in the long run
so not
impacted
by
m
in
the
long run
well if you assume that these two things
are relatively constant well then you
will see this direct relationship
between your price level and the
quantity of money now in practice this
is likely to be an oversimplification
like most of our economics models
for example coming out of the last
recession of 2008-2009
the federal reserve practiced
quantitative easing where they
dramatically increased the money supply
right over here but we did not see a
commensurate dramatic increase in
inflation in the price level now some
folks could argue that when the federal
reserve in 2008 dramatically increased
the money supply without a dramatic
increase in price levels it might have
been because the velocity of money went
down that people weren't actually
transacting with all of that money that
was being injected into the system who
knows and if you're always able to use
velocity is a bit of a fudge factor well
then it puts into debate of how useful
this might be but needless to say it is
an interesting model to at least think
about that if the money supply were to
increase dramatically and people
transact at roughly the same rate but
the actual output that the economy is
producing isn't changing it makes some
level of common sense that maybe that
would increase the price level you'd
have more money chasing the same output